i gotta remember to be sure i'm not set
to be cremated when i die
dark water so here we go with part one
of the two part
series finale for series eight of doctor
who and
it's pretty good but exactly how good
it's going to be is
really going to hinge on what happens in
the next episode and then this is going
to be
really hard for me to talk about spoiler
free because all the stuff that i want
to talk about and all the stuff that i'm
sure
people have actually seen the episode
are talking about is all spoilers
pretty much because what we get is a
fairly
large amount of answers in terms of
stuff that we knew was gonna be
addressed in terms of the character of
missy that we've seen this
place that's been called heaven or the
promised land or the nethersphere or
whatever they felt like calling it
we get some answers on that and that's
all spoilers so i can't really talk
about what i will say
uh in regards to missy specifically i'm
on board so far
with with what we find out about her
i've got some
things that might unhinge it for me but
i'm waiting for the next episode to see
if those concerns get addressed and i
can completely roll with it
god you know there's almost nothing i
can talk about this i don't even want to
talk about the initial setup and what
happens at the very beginning of the
episode because even though
i generally consider first five minutes
of episode fair game in terms of talking
about stuff
i don't even want to say what happens
there because i wasn't expecting it i
didn't see it coming and i think
anyone who watches the episode for the
first time i hope they won't see you
coming either i don't want to wreck that
for you
but there's a number of really
interesting reveals and it's kind of
funny because there's basically two
notable reveals
that happened over the course of this
episode one of which the show itself
actually kind of spoiled in his
promotional material intentionally
and then the other of which i i don't
want to say i completely had spoiled but
i had
seen people uh put out fan theories that
effectively was
what ended up happening and i usually
try to avoid fan theory partly for that
reason
but it's funny it was actually a fan
theory i completely discounted going
that's ridiculous and even when it
happened in the show i was kind
of i kind of still felt that's
ridiculous but it may still work
but sort of backing up to the other
reveal the one that the show itself has
actually kind of wrecked in promotional
materials though
for whatever reason i had completely
forgotten about
i don't know why i usually always
remember this sort of stuff
but for whatever reason it slipped my
mind while i was watching the episode
and just
i can't say what it is specifically but
just the way visually it's done because
it's done with just this really simple
moment
and this familiar musical cue kicking in
and
i just had this moment of oh and then
the true
full reveal of what it was that was
going on and what characters were
involved in this i thought was
fantastically executed it's this sort of
thing of the thing that's going to be
revealed almost the whole episode
it's staring you in the face but you
don't recognize it for what it is
and i love that i love when a story a
show a movie anything can
pull that off because it's a really hard
thing to do without
feeling like it's cheating and this
doesn't cheat it does it legitimately it
doesn't terrifically
character work is all solid on this as
it has been sort of what goes on between
clara and the doctor in the earlier
portion that's some pretty heavy stuff
that happens
but as i keep banging on about over and
over again i'm ready for her to go but
she's
she has been really good this series i'm
not gonna say she wasn't
more great stuff from danny pink he has
just really turned out to be
a very well played character very well
conceived character and a very well
utilized character what they do to him
and with him to bring out certain
aspects of clara and the doctor it's
it's all just been really well
orchestrated
the doctor himself oddly seems slightly
like
he's put on the back burner in this
story because one of the main
crux of a lot of what's going on is not
him directly
i mean he's trying to figure out what's
going on but he he feels
slightly to the side of a lot of this
episode now that said what happens at
the very end of this episode puts him
much more front and center so i expect
him to really take the reins in the
finale
so based on that assumption i was okay
with it now if that isn't what happens
and he still
feels peripheral in the actual last
episode that's gonna end up sort of
retroactively becoming an issue
but right now as the first half of a
two-part story
gripping stuff and the way it ends the
cliffhanger on which it ends
which has multiple layers to it in terms
of what
it leaves you hanging going but but
and i just hope that the payoff works as
well
as this first half setup was so doctor
who
usually has at least one two-parter in
every series so what was the two-parter
for you the first half that really left
you going ah
how could i possibly wait a week to get
the answers to this
what one was that for you was it this
one we just saw or was there another one
that hit you
with that even harder whichever one it
was drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it until next time
this council
is adjourned
you